democrats green light anti-semitism in
the most disgusting
possible way the democratic party bars
fox news from a primary debate and the
illegal immigration crisis
is real i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
[Music]
well get ready for an hour of rage
because i am
livid this morning livid i spent two
years
fighting anti-semitism from the right i
spent legitimately two years taking on
the alt-right
every single day being threatened with
death a lot of times i was the number
one recipient of alt-right hate for two
years
in the united states and now the same
left that said that they were on my side
when it came to fighting anti-semitism
it turns out they were completely
full of okay we'll get to all that in
just one second but first but first
you may need to relax you may need to
fix your back after a workout well the
best way to do that
is to hang upside down i know sounds
weird right but it is actually a great
way to decompress the back and joints
after a workout and boost recovery it's
called inversion therapy
it uses gravity and your own body weight
to decompress the spine and release
tension in your shoulders neck and
joints
inverting after your workout boosts the
recovery process by stretching and
elongating your spine and joints
rehydrating the discs and relaxing tired
muscles
decompressing on a teeter inversion
table for a few minutes a day is a great
addition to your daily routine to
maintain a healthy back and joints
i love this thing i've done my homework
this is the best inversion table on the
market which is why over three million
people have put their trust
in teeter in fact my personal trainer is
a guy who's experiencing significant
neck pain he goes home he gets on that
teeter inversion table to help him
they're offering a great deal just for
my listeners for a limited time you can
get the brand new 2019 teeter fit spine
inversion table model with bonus
accessories and a free pair of gravity
boots so you can invert at home or take
the boots with you
to the gym tutor and version tables have
thousands of reviews on amazon
average 4.6 star rating with this deal
you get 150 bucks off
when you go to teeter.com that's
t-e-e-t-e-r dot com slash ben you also
get free shipping
free return 60-day money-back guarantee
so there's absolutely no risk to trying
it out remember you can only get the new
2019 teeter-fit spine inversion table
plus
a free pair of gravity boots by going to
teeter.com that's t-e-e-t-e-r
dot com slash ben to decompress well now
that you're decompressed
it's time to compress again okay the
fact is the democratic party has decided
to wholesale embrace anti-semitism
not a little bit not some wholesale
wholesale embrace anti-semitism
so as you know ilhan omar is a vicious
anti-semite there's been a lot of talk
in the last day or so about how ilhan
omar
wasn't actually saying anything
anti-semitic she was just saying stuff
that was anti-israel
oh now this is a convenient excuse very
often for people who are anti-semitic
not all anti-israel commentary is
anti-semitic
you can criticize the israeli government
i do it regularly i've done it twice in
the last three months i believe
so this this sort of thing is perfectly
normal you can criticize any government
you can criticize them for any reason
what you cannot do
is criticize jews as a stand-in for
israel ilhan omar is not being
criticized today because she was
critical of israel virtually every
member of the democratic caucus has been
because the democratic party
has moved in a dramatically anti-israel
fashion for a very long time
that does not necessarily mean
anti-semitic but
the same people who proclaim that
anti-israel and anti-semitic are not the
same thing
will then say that open anti-semitism is
not anti-semitism it's just anti-israel
and that's what is happening right now
they say on the left
don't conflate anti-israel with
anti-semitic and we say
okay seems fair right like i think that
there's not a great excuse for why you
would oppose the only democracy in the
region and side with
you know an actual terrorist government
in the gaza strip and an actual
terrorist government
in judea and samaria i'm not sure what
would motivate that but
if you want to criticize particular
actions of the israeli government
have at it just like we have added here
in the united states when we criticize
the actions
of the american government that's
politics but the same people who say
listen
my criticism of israel isn't
anti-semitic it's just criticism of
israel
then when somebody says stuff that is
openly anti-semitic
then they say hey no no that's not you
hatred that's just us being anti-israel
you don't get to have it both ways
either anti-israel and anti-semitic are
not the same thing
or anti-semitism and anti-israel
activity
are the same thing what you don't get to
do is separate the two
and then when someone says jew-hating
garbage like like ilhan omar does
consistently
you hide that under the rubric of oh
she's just being anti-israel
here is the thing she has not said
anything about israel
every comment about which she has been
criticized has nothing to do with israel
and everything to do with the jews writ
large
she's been criticized for three specific
statements lest we forget the media is
lying about all this today
i'm not going to let them lie about this
she said three specific things for which
she has been criticized
and maybe four if you include her wish
to side with the bds movement
the bds movement doesn't just suggest
that israel is wrong in the palestinian
conflict
the leaders of the bds movement have
openly stated they want the destruction
of the state of israel
there is no way to talk about the
destruction of the state of israel with
talking about without talking about
the death or expulsion of millions of
jews that's where
israel policy shades over into
anti-semitism if you stand for the
destruction of the state of israel
that is anti-semitic anti-zionism at
this point
is anti-semitic but that is not the same
thing as criticizing specific actions
of the israeli government or suggesting
a two-state solution
none of that is anti-semitic okay but
she didn't even we're not even talking
about that that's not the stuff she did
she was not even talking about israel at
all okay here are the three comments for
which she has been criticized she's not
been criticized for the bds stuff really
she should be but she has not been okay
but here are the three comments for
which ilhan omar the representative from
minnesota
was criticized she was criticized one
for stating that israel
hypnotizes the world that is not a
criticism
of the israeli government that is a
suggestion that the nefarious jews in
the jewish state
are using their magical jew powers to
ensure that israel has
support across the world that
independent people across the world are
not supporting israel
because israel has certain principles
because it's a liberal democracy
because it's a homeland for historically
persecuted people who have been
slaughtered on mass for something like
3 000 years no it's that israel and the
nefarious jews hypnotize the world that
is blatant anti-semitism
that's statement number one she quasi
apologized for it she said
she didn't really understand originally
how that could be offensive to jews i
mean she was just talking about israel
but she wasn't talking about israeli
policy
she was talking about the jewish state
hypnotizing the world
second she said that american support
for israel was quote unquote all about
the benjamins and then she cited to
aipac
what she meant by that obviously is that
jewish american money was behind
american support for israel
this is another anti-semitic
anti-semitic comment
it has nothing to do with israel policy
israel does not put money into aipac
aipac is an american lobbying
organization funded by israel supporters
many of whom are jewish
when she says the reason that americans
support israel is specifically because
the jews are paying them off to do so
it is all about the benjamins she is
suggesting
that the jews are in nefarious fashion
paying off various politicians
and corruptly causing them to be
pro-israel
that that's that's the thing here it's
these nefarious jews and their
pro-israel ways
that is it that is an anti-semitic
comment it's not anti-israel because
again it's not a critique of anything
the israeli government is doing
it is not a critique of the state of
israel it is a critique
of jews in america who are spreading
their nefarious jew money around
and causing america to support israel
that was her second statement for which
shequazi apologized although she didn't
really apologize for that
then she made a third statement her
third statement was that supporters of
israel
jewish non-jewish supporters of israel
have dual loyalty to israel
now if she's talking about jews in that
group that is an anti-semitic statement
the suggestion that the reason that
american jews support israel
is because they are secret nefarious
agents of the jewish state
is a canard that has been used against
jews for legitimately thousands of years
going back to a time when there was no
israel remember israel was only
established in 1948 anti-semitism
did not begin with the establishment of
the jewish state i know that those on
the left
like to conflate anti-semitism and
anti-israeli activity
they like to say that every act of
anti-semitism is really rooted in
israeli policy
it turns out anti-semitism has quite a
history before that
the holocaust took place before the
state of israel existed the pogroms in
1929 in cavron in
hebron in israel by arabs against jews
those took place before there was a
state of israel
pogroms in eastern europe were taking
place regularly the ghettoization of
jews in europe that was taking place
regularly the treatment of jews as
second-class citizens in the muslim
world that was taking place
long before there was in israel so and
one of the canards that was used was
that
the jews were a group of people who were
internally loyal but externally disloyal
that they were a cancer in the body
politic that they had dual loyalty
that they weren't truly loyal to the
country to which they in which they
lived or the principles
of the country in which they lived truly
they were loyal only to each other this
tribal clannish group
that was the that was the canard that
has been used against jews really since
time immemorial i mean going all the way
back to pharaoh
in egypt suggesting that the jews keep
to themselves
so these are all anti-semitic trumps
again not one of these comments has
anything to do with israel
so what do the democrats do the
democrats say well no i guess it has to
do with israel
her comments really have to do with
israel and you're trying to shut down
debate about israel
when you say that she's being
anti-semitic again
not any of her comments have to do with
israel you know that democrats are lying
and they are covering up that lie by
proclaiming that they are just
trying to open the debate about israel
itself but again she didn't say anything
about israel
and it is amazing to watch as the
democrats are incapable
completely incapable of stopping the
anti-semitism rising from within their
ranks because for the democrats
not all hate is equal there's a great
irony to this you'll recall that over
the last 48 hours
there was talk about a resolution
condemning anti-semitism then
the democrats decided to water it down
by adding islamophobia then
they suggested that they were going to
advance a symbolic resolution
condemning all hate entirely but the
real rationale for doing this is to
write out anti-semitism as hate
because they couldn't even pass that
they then delayed that resolution
they couldn't even condemn all hate
because here's the truth the democrats
don't give any dams about all hate
they don't they care about the hatred
that unifies their base that's it
they cared about anti-semitism so long
as they could attribute it to the
alt-right and attribute it to president
trump the minute
that it turns out that a huge percentage
of their base is fine with anti-semitism
then anti-semitism takes a back seat
this is nothing new the new york times
reported this back in october the new
york times
spent years ignoring the uptick in
anti-semitic hate crimes in new york
city and they admitted full scale in the
new york times the reason we didn't
cover this is because it wasn't white
supremacists that is the logic of the
left not that all anti-semitism is bad
not that anti-semitism is worth
condemnation
no the idea is that anti-semitism is
only bad if we can attribute it to our
political opponents if we're doing it
then it's not really anti-semitism then
it's just us being anti-israel
then it's just you know look is is
anti-semitism really such a problem in
the united states like should we really
worry about
ilhan amar being anti-systematic isn't
she more of a victim
than the jews who she is accusing of
nefarious
protocols of the elders of zion style
conspiracies behind closed doors
isn't she the real victim here this is
how democrats
have reacted to all of this speaker
nancy pelosi said we'll see what the
committee comes up with
i'm a big believer in the committee
system this is their jurisdiction they
have an array of concerns
priorities they are addressing by the
way there's been no push by the
democrats to oust ilhan omar from the
foreign affairs committee
right so it's it's amazing they'll
suggest that anti-semitism has nothing
to do with anti-israel activity then
they cover with that for anti-semitism
by attributing it to anti-israel
activity
then the anti-semite they are covering
for gets to sit on a committee that
oversees
israel american relations perfect how
that works out
in a second i'm going to talk about what
the democrats are supposedly doing here
what the democrats are supposedly doing
and then we'll get to their actual
responses their actual responses
are mind-blowing and revelatory and
remind you
that the democratic party does not and
has not taken anti-semitism in its own
ranks seriously
by any measure whatsoever any measure
there are those of us who took it
seriously from the right and take it
seriously from the left
i'm still looking for the people on the
left willing to take anti-semitism in
their own ranks
seriously enough to call this garbage
out for what it is
but before we get to that first we need
to calm down we need to calm down
stress is a worldwide epidemic we are
working longer hours we're inundated
with the constant news cycle we're more
connected than ever before stress is a
part of life it can very easily affect
our overall well-being
and that's why we're partnering with
calm it's the number one app to help you
reduce your anxiety and stress
and help you sleep better more than 40
million people around the world have
downloaded it
if you head over to calm.com ben you'll
get 25
off a calm premium subscription that
includes guided meditations on issues
like anxiety stress and focus
including a brand new meditation every
day i mean this stuff is just great they
also have sleep stories
these are bedtime stories for adults
designed to help you relax i am not
great at sleeping and i'll tell you
calm.com
definitely works for me head to the
magical lavender fields of southern
france with stephen fry or explore the
moonlit jungles of africa with leona
lewis
they even have soothing music and more
so if you're looking to calm down and
decompress
after a long day of following politics
right now head over to calm.com ben my
listeners get 25
off a calm premium subscription at
calm.com
ben that's c-a-l-m-com ben get unlimited
access to all of columns content today
at calm.combengetcalm and stop
stressing so tonight after the show i
will definitely be listening to a lot of
calm.comcalm.com
i'm gonna need it okay back to being
stressed out so here is what the
democratic party
is doing about anti-semitism the answer
is nothing
nothing members involved is according to
the daily beast
members involved in crafting the
resolution have already been hit with
requests from the offices of democratic
lawmakers for specific groups to be
included in the resolution
so now they're just going to broaden out
what was a single-issue resolution
to include hatred against people of all
faiths
and all kinds now i'm old enough to
remember when the black lives matter
movement said
black lives matter and people said all
lives matter it's not just black lives
now the left immediately interpreted
that to mean
that if you said all lives matter you
were seeking to obscure the fact that
black lives matter
those exact same people are saying today
that if you broaden out
an anti-semitism resolution specifically
based on a specific circumstance to
include all hatred that's not watering
anything down
it's amazing how that works by the way i
will mention that when it comes to the
black lives matter all lives matter
distinction
the reason people said all lives matter
is because they rejected the fundamental
premise
that black people were being unfairly
targeted by the police across the
country
that's what the actual argument was
about there is no argument that
anti-semitism exists
and there is no rational argument that
ilhan omar is a purveyor of
anti-semitism
so this isn't even like the black lives
matter all lives matter debate because
there is no good
faith reason to broaden this thing out
except to obscure ilhan omar's
participation in anti-semitism
but that's what the democrats are
seeking to do in a second i'm going to
explain more of what they are doing
representative tulsi gabbard who is
hindu reached out to top democrats to
ask that hindus be specifically
mentioned in the resolution
other members have suggested catholics
muslims and all forms of racism should
be added too pelosi then replied what's
too broad about fighting hatred
wherever it exists well first of all
you're not fighting hatred where it
exists
your representative sits on the foreign
affairs committee you have said that she
is not anti-semitic and that she did not
participate in anti-semitism
representative pelosi pelosi was
specifically asked about this
she said she didn't think that el
hanover's comments were intentionally
anti-semitic
what in the hell does that even mean
intentionally anti-semitic what she was
walking along the street she slipped in
a puddle and boom she started spouting
anti-jew hatred
and it happens to me all the time just
walking down the street anvil falls on
my head
and suddenly i'm shouting about the kkk
being great ilhan omar
does this stuff every two weeks she
can't help herself
intentionally anti-semitic by wednesday
afternoon
several of the democrats had taken to
blaming the media for covering omar's
remarks
claiming that racist and anti-semitic
actions and language from republicans
were being ignored
we have to do better across the board
said representative max rose now this is
peak whataboutism peak what about ism we
can't condemn ilhanamar we won't condemn
el hanomar because
over there there's a person go get him
okay now
let's be straight about this the attempt
to equate ilhan omar's comments
with for example representative jim
jordan
tweeting out tom steyer with a dollar
sign in tom steyer's name
is absurd tom steyer isn't jewish he's
episcopalian
also to say that a particular person
gives a lot of money to politics
say george soros is not anti-semitic to
say that the jews writ large are
controlling american politics on behalf
of israel
that's anti-semitic george soros does
give a lot of money
to politics it's not anti-semitic to
point that out any more than it would be
anti-semitic
for someone to point out that i speak on
politics every day
because i do that's a reality
that is not the same thing as saying ben
shapiro and all the jews are paying
people off with their jew money
to support israel that's anti-semitic
but look the democrats are not the the
intellectual dishonesty the willingness
to overlook
all of this to pander to their
intersectional new faces it's
astonishing it's astonishing
let's be real the real reason the new
york times didn't cover the hate crime
uptick in new york city is because the
purveyors were largely for minority
groups statistically speaking they
weren't going to cover that
they weren't going to cover that because
for the democrats not all hatred is to
be condemned
only hatred that affects the
intersectional coalition
only hatred that helps them coalesce
their various bands
of supposedly dispossessed victim groups
and jews aren't to be included in that
even though they are the smallest of
these victim groups and the most likely
to be targeted by hate crimes
because that might divide the democratic
base intersectionality is a dangerous
drug
democrats have been taking it and now
they've od'd
representative john yarmuth said we've
already voted on it he said whatever we
do it's going to look like we're
responding specifically to her and
aipac well it should look like you're
responding specifically to ilhan omar
she's the one who started this
represent majority whip james clyburn
conceded some members felt omar had been
singled out for her comments
he said of all the hate of all hate all
hate all hate all hate
anti-semitism islamophobia racism all
that stuff
and then james clyburn let the cat out
of the bag then james clarbon really let
the cat out of the bag
you ready for the ugliest garbage you've
ever heard from majority
whip jim's cl james clabrin of south
carolina you're right this is from the
hill
clyburn came to omar's defense on
wednesday lamenting
that many of the media reports
surrounding the recent controversy
have omitted mentioning that omar who
was born in somalia had to flee the
country
to escape violence and spent four years
in a kenyan refugee camp before coming
to the united states
her experience clyburn argued is much
more empirical and powerful
than that of people who are generations
removed from the holocaust
japanese internment camps during world
war ii and then the other violent
episodes that have marked history
i'm serious about that there are people
who tell me while my parents are
holocaust survivors my parents did this
it's more personal with her clydeburn
said i've talked to her and i can tell
you
she is living through a lot of pain
this is vile vile so
anti-semitism no longer matters because
you see oh han omar suffered
you know who else suffered ion hersey
ali you know what the left has done with
iron hirsciale
they've othered her they've decided that
she cannot be heard
they've tried to ban her from campuses
because she's anti-radical islam
they've done that she had the same ex
worse experiences than
ilhan amar i'm not aware that ilhanimar
was a victim of female genital
mutilation as ayan herciali was
it doesn't matter ayan hersey ali has
been ousted by the democrats and othered
by the democrats
but don't worry ilhanamar can be as
anti-semitic as she wants to because who
cares about the holocaust it happened so
long ago now imagine for a second
a republican saying about the history of
slavery
you know what people should stop
complaining that america enslaved people
they really should stop complaining
about it all together like we shouldn't
even mention it
and if somebody says something racist
today that is linked to the legacy of
slavery
if somebody says something about
enslaving black people today that is
linked to the legacy of slavery
we shouldn't those 150 years ago were
you enslaved happened a long time ago
people on the left would be angry to
suggest
that because you had people who died in
the holocaust well you haven't suffered
what is this competitive suffering this
isn't about who has suffered more
this is about a person expressing open
jew hatred and james clyburn making
excuses for it because he wants to kiss
ilhan omar's ass
and the asses of all of her friends aoc
rashida talib
rokahana this is james clyburn cow
towing
and it's also about an unfortunate fact
the congressional black caucus
has tolerated anti-semitism for years
they've been close with louis ferricon
they've been close with a bunch of
figure linda sarsour they've gone out of
their way to cultivate relationships
with people
who have been ousted from the overton
window
of american politics for decades now
the cbc coming out in defense of ilhan
omar is just the latest iteration of
this garbage
james clyburn really we can't
the my parents are holocaust survivors
listen if the holocaust had never taken
place you know it would still be wrong
jew hatred
that would still be wrong but for the
democrats there is this intersectional
pyramid
el hanomar is higher on the
intersectional pyramid she's from
somalia she's muslim she's a woman
that means she can be as anti-semitic
and disgusting as she wants to be
so that is the hottest take of they but
it's not the only take
of the day we'll get to the other
democratic takes on all of this in a
second and then i will show you
how this has played out in europe
because we know where this is going
folks we know where this is going
it is not a secret the democratic party
is becoming the jeremy corbyn labour
party of the uk
which means that america is likely to go
the direction of europe when it comes to
anti-semitism more generally if this
continues i'll explain in just a second
first
let's talk about preserving your family
memories i've
said for a long time that i am very very
big
on helping to preserve family memories
because in the end that's really all
you're gonna have
and here are a few reasons why so many
people are motivated and excited to
digitize their old analog format with
legacy box what you really need to do
is ensure that all of those old photos
in your garage all that old film that
that is digitized and updated and then
you can have it convenient to you
on a thumb drive or on a dvd save your
family films and photos from degrading
or being lost
forever play your videos that you
haven't been able to play in years
because you don't have a vcr anymore
this gives you peace of mind and a great
sense of accomplishment makes a
fantastic gift
to parents to siblings to spouses send
your legacy box filled with old home
movies and pictures and then legacy box
does the rest they will professionally
digitize your moments onto a thumb drive
a digital download or a dvd
they have easy to follow instructions
and safety barcodes included for every
item
receive all your original moments
recorded moments back
along with a perfectly preserved digital
copy and get personalized updates at
every step
receive up to 12 personalized email
updates legacy box is the world's
largest most trusted digitizer of home
movies and photos
over 450 000 families trust legacy box
there's never been a better time to
digitally preserve those memories
visit legacybox.com i really think this
is an incredibly important gift plus for
a limited time they're offering my
listeners an exclusive discount go to
legacybox.com
ben and get 40 off your first order that
is legacybox.com
say 40 today my family has done this and
you should too legacybox.com
save 40 today go check them out right
now
okay so it's not just james clyburn who
is presenting
pretty much openly anti-semitic
arguments at this point i mean clyburn's
argument is an openly anti-semitic one
anti-semitism is fine jew hatred is fine
so long as you can say you're a member
of a more victimized group or you've had
more victimized experiences but that's
not the only terrible argument coming
from the democrats today
every major democratic presidential
candidate who has
commented on this has come out now in
defense of ilhan omar in the most
dishonest possible way
so bernie sanders now people will say
that bernie sanders
because he's a jew that he has more
legitimacy on this
bullcrap bernie sanders has no more
legitimacy on this than anyone else
he is not a practicing jew he has not
been for a long time he is an atheist he
is self-stated he's an
atheist he has no real identification
with
a shul with the jewish community with
jewish principles or any of that stuff
so spare me the he can't be saying
things in defense of anti-semitism he's
a jew
of course he can so here is him
defending anti-semitism from ilhanomar
quote
anti-semitism is a hateful and dangerous
ideology which must be vigorously
opposed in the united states and around
the world
we must not however equate anti-semitism
with legitimate criticism of the
right-wing netanyahu government
in israel hey no one has done that
no one again not a comment ilhan omar is
being criticized for
has anything to do with benjamin
netanyahu not one word that she has says
has anything to do with israeli policy
it all has to do with the powers of the
nefarious jews and their dual loyalty
that is what she is being ripped for if
you were just about opposing israel
then don't you think that every democrat
would be hit with this kind of stuff
legitimately like all of them because
how many democrats
stood up against barack obama's insane
iran deal that put the existence of the
jewish state at risk
virtually none was chuck schumer called
an anti-semite for that
no he was not so there was something
different that happened here
obviously but bernie sanders is playing
this game
they're playing the sick disgusting game
where they say anti-israel is not the
same as anti-semitism
here is a person saying a very
anti-semitic thing and we will pretend
it is an anti-israel thing you ever
wonder why so many jews
seem to get very touchy when people
start talking about how much they hate
israel
and how much they think that israel is
is the evildoer in the middle east and
you say why are they so touchy and i'm
not touching when they criticize
my american party the answer is because
a lot of jews look
at your commentary on israel in which
you incessantly criticize israel and
they say you might be an anti-semite and
you say well i'm not okay well maybe
you're
not but it's weird because all of the
anti-semites all of them are anti-israel
how odd how odd and not only that all
the anti-semites will guide their
anti-semitism under the
oh i'm just anti-israel canard and
bernie sanders
is doing that today he says rather we
must develop an even-handed middle east
policy
which brings israelis and palestinians
together for a lasting peers
peace what i fear is going on in the
house now is an effort to target
congresswoman omar as a way of stifling
that debate
f you f you bernie sanders
honest to god what i fear is an effort
to target omar
to stifle the debate what debate there's
no debate
she didn't mean to start a debate about
the power of aipac
about whether aipac's lobbying power is
is
outsized which by for the record it is
not apac spends less money on elections
than virtually every other group that is
connected with the
with the promotion of of connections
with a foreign country
right there is a cuba there's a there's
a cuban lobby there's a mexican lobby
there is in fact an irish lobby all
these lobbies exist
but for the record that's not what she's
talking about
there is no debate here she wasn't
trying to start a debate she was saying
jew-hating things and bernie sanders is
trying to subsume that under the ruby oh
she's she's just not quite it's real
that's all
and this has become the talking point
for the democrats so what they want to
say
is anti-israel doesn't mean anti-semitic
but if you say something anti-semitic
we'll let it go because it's probably
just anti-israel
senator elizabeth warren does the same
thing she says we have a moral duty to
combat hateful ideologies in our own
country and around the world
and that includes both anti-semitism and
islamophobia
again the fact that they feel the need
to link the two
as though the real story here is people
being mean to ilhan omar
the real story is a west virginia gop
poster condemned by pretty much everyone
that that is that is somehow equivalent
to a sitting member of congress
consistently not once three times in six
weeks saying openly anti-semitic stuff
and not being condemned by her own party
equating the two okay but that's not
that's not all she says in a democracy
we can and should have an open
respectful debate about the middle east
that focuses on policy
branding criticism of israel as
automatically anti-semitic has a
chilling effect on our public discourse
threats of violence like those made
against representative omar are never
acceptable
who's making threats of violence against
ilhan omar and if they are shouldn't
they be arrested that's a violation of
the law
but notice how she conflates that again
again for the one millionth time this
show
i'm not saying and no one has said that
all criticism of israel is anti-semitic
i am saying that if you use
anti-semitism and then cover for it
by saying no i'm just being anti-israel
then you are an anti-semite and an
anti-semite enabler
kamala harris does the same thing she's
even worse kamala harris
garbage senator from california she says
we all have a senator we all have a
responsibility to speak out against
anti-semitism
islamophobia homophobia transphobia
racism blah blah blah blah blah blah but
like some of my colleagues in the
congressional black caucus
i am concerned that the spotlight being
put
on congresswoman omar may put her at
risk
what so let's so she says something
wildly anti-semitic not once
three times if we pay attention to this
we are the bad people because we are
putting her at risk i don't remember her
same concern for steve king's safety do
you
representative king who defended
quasi-white nationalism
remember this he did this in the new
york times some of us called on people
to support
a primary effort from senator randy
feenstra in iowa who should go support
today
some of us called on the house to
censure steve king and remove him from
committee assignments
i'm old enough to remember that because
i'm more than two months old
but apparently democrats are not old
enough to remember that they are very
concerned about congresswoman omar's
safety
because people might say things that
remind people of what she said
unbelievable and then there's
congressperson emmanuel cleaver
he says i think there ought to be a
resolution that ought to be condemning
all the isms if we're going to start
condemning let's condemn sexism
homophobia islamophobia
everything oh all lives matter that's
where
all lives matter by the way the cbc was
so defensive of ilhan omar that when she
tried to escape questions yesterday they
literally formed an offensive line and
pushed away journalists
were the journalists angry no of course
not
were they upset no of course not today
all of the major newspapers in the
united states are filled with editorials
supporting ilhan omar and suggesting
that the blowback on her
is really about conservatives pouncing
it's really about the pouncing of the
conservatives
now listen we know where all of this is
going okay this is not a shock we know
where all of this is going in europe and
i'm going to explain
where it has gone in europe in just one
second first you're going to have to go
over to dailywire.com and subscribe
for 9.99 a month you can get a
subscription to daily wire when you do
you get the rest of the show live you
get the rest of
andrew clavin's show live michael
knowles the show plus you get two
additional hours of me this afternoon
we're having on today the head of the
council of jewish presidents malcolm
heinlein to talk
about this particular scandal among the
democrats we'll give you all the updates
throughout the day
basically our show lasts all day at this
point and that's why you should tune in
and you should subscribe
for 99 a year you get that plus the
greatest in all beverage vessels the
leftist tiers hot or cold tumbler
look at it doesn't it make you feel
better just looking it makes me feel
better so go check that out right now
when you subscribe you also get our
sunday special on saturdays we have so
many good sunday specials coming up like
a bunch of them this week
it's arthur brooks of american
enterprise institute the author of love
your enemies he stops by and then i
can't announce who our next sunday
special guests are going to be
let me just say amazing amazing so this
is why you want to be part of the team
over at dailywire.com for 99 a year or
9.99
a month go check it out right now and
please leave us a review at youtube and
itunes and follow us and subscribe
we are the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
america
[Music]
now we know where all of this is going
and it is fascinating to watch as all of
it
has morphed it's it's really incredible
to watch as the excuses have more so it
started with
el hanomar didn't know what she was
saying yeah it's anti-semitic but she's
ignorant
right she's an ignorant woman
legitimately this was the case that was
made
by heads of the democratic party she
didn't know what she was saying she
needs education guys
it's really just about edumacation if we
just told her
that she was saying mean things she
would stop saying mean things now never
mind
that there was an article in the
minneapolis star tribune years ago
talking about how the jewish community
had met with ilhan omar and left feeling
she was anti-semitic basically
and that people have been trying to
quote unquote educate ilhan omar about
this stuff for years to no avail which
suggests perhaps
she knows precisely what she is doing it
started with
oh you know it's just ignorant it's just
ignorant so then it turned into
well you know it's bad right the
anti-semitism is bad
sure but what's really bad is that
donald trump is president that's really
bad like let's pay attention to trump
because you know
two years ago trump was winking and
nodding at the alt-right and that means
we shouldn't cover omar i mean that
would be
it wouldn't be even-handed of us to
ignore president trump at this time
number one no one ignored trump at the
time
i was there i was one of the people
yelling at him
but democrats moved to the what about
ism okay we're not going to pay
attention to omar
trump is still out there and he's the
real threat
and then it turned into you know what
it's not anti-semitism at all poof
it's just anti-israel sentiment it's
just her being anti and we can't shut
down the debate
we wouldn't want to shut down the debate
and then it turned into
you know what even if it's anti-semitic
that's okay because i mean after all
she's from somalia
after all she's more victimized than you
and that's okay that's okay that she
says anti-semitic things because she's a
victim you see
so it is morphed it's morphed all the
way now where is this going what is the
logical endpoint to all of this
here is the logical endpoint this is an
image this is an image
that was posted by labor leadership
okay this is an ally of jeremy corbyn
who directed
that a labor member posted an
anti-semitic image from a far right
website
okay so there was a labor member who
posted this image if you can't see the
image because you're not subscribing
the image is a picture of the alien from
the movie aliens
over the face of the statue of liberty
with a jewish star on the back of it
with a jewish star on the back of it so
the jewish
lobster-like evil alien over the face of
the statue of liberty with the jewish
star on the back of it blatant
anti-semitic imagery direct from the
pages of der sturmer i mean this is nazi
type imagery
and it was posted by a person named
kayla bibby kayla baby posted
an anti-semitic image with the star of
david on the statue of liberty
and then she added the most accurate
photo i've seen all year
she attended labor's conference in
september as a delegate from the
liverpool riverside constituency and was
led off with a warning
but now an ally of jeremy corbyn
directed
that a labor member should not face
immediate suspension because
this was just anti-israel not
anti-jewish
you see open anti-semitism is really
just anti-israel stuff
that's all it's just about israel
now what exactly did that picture have
to do with israel nothing it was the
jews control america they're an alien
life form on the face of the united
states
don't worry it's just anti-israel and
the logical extension goes even further
than that
in 2014 there was a bomb attack an arson
attack on a synagogue in brussels
it was a synagogue in actually it was in
dusseldorf sorry
and in in germany and the dusseldorf
high court
found no procedural errors in the trials
of three men of palestinian descent for
felony arson against a
wooper tall synagogue so they tried to
burn down a synagogue in 2014
and the high court the high court said
them burning down a synagogue
not in israel in germany them trying to
burn down a synagogue in germany
was an expression not of anti-jew hatred
it was an expression
of anti-israel sentiment is an
expression
of anti-israel sentiment that's all that
it was
okay katharina von schnierbein the eu's
coordinator on anti-semitism
she spoke on a panel exploring the new
anti-semitism she said in my opinion
throwing molotov cocktails into a
synagogue is always anti-semitism but
really is it
really is it is it really anti-semitism
when you use a bunch of jew-hating
language
but you're also anti-israel isn't that
really just you hating on israel
when you suggest that the nefarious jews
are behind american politics
and their nefarious jew money is behind
american politics that's just you being
anti-israel right
and burning down synagogues i mean if
you're doing that because you don't like
israel i mean we all get it don't we
the arson attack on the berggish shiniga
synagogue in wuppertal took place
in the early morning hours of july 29
following an end to ramadan celebration
and during the height of anti-israel
protests in germany
and elsewhere over the gaza war the men
were found guilty of arson and given
suspended sentences in 2015
with a threat of jail if they got into
trouble again the high court last month
rejected the defendant's appeal
on procedural grounds
in a statement last week moshe kanter
who's the president of the european
jewish congress said it was unbelievable
that attempts to burn a synagogue have
been equated with displeasure with
israeli government policies but again
this is nothing new we have seen in
france groups of men
largely of of middle eastern muslim
descent
descending on shuls on synagogues and
attacking those synagogues whenever
there's an israeli policy they don't
like
because jews everywhere are obviously
merely foreign agents of the israeli
government
that's where the democratic party is
going that any form of anti-semitism
is apparently going to be justified with
well you know they were just ilhan omar
was just pissed off at israel that's all
so doesn't that make this okay we know
where we know where this is going guys
okay this is not a shock it's already
happening in europe i thought that the
core
the jeremy corbynization of the
democratic party was going to take
longer it took about five
minutes five minutes the new wave of
democrats are jeremy corbyn
aoc is a fan of jeremy corbyn she touted
that she had a call with the guy jeremy
corbyn has spoken out in favor of hamas
in favor of hezbollah he has tolerated
the growth of open anti-semitism in his
own party he's just said oh well it's
just anti-israel activity
that's all so here's a question for
american jews today
i want you to vote overwhelmingly for
the democrats look at the democratic
party and ask yourself
is this a party that you can justify
voting for
is this i'm not even asking you to vote
republican you vote however you want
but can you bring yourself to vote in
favor of a party that is willing to let
off
anti-semitism this way in favor of the
quote-unquote intersectional ideal
i mean when you've lost your under
sargon i don't know what to tell you
anger sargon is the editor of the jewish
forward and she is
bent over backwards i mean legitimately
bent over backwards to try and make
excuses
for anti-semites inside the democrat
ranks because she's tried to give them
the benefit
of the doubt but even now but now even
she is saying
you know there's no way to justify this
there's no way to justify this i'll
explain in just a second so by anger
sargon i know her she's a nice lady we
disagree about politics
but she has really bent over backwards
to try and make excuses
for ilhan omar and rashida talib even
she is saying i can't handle this
anymore
she wrote a column in the forward which
is a far left far left jewish magazine
the kind of jewish magazine that
suggests that i am a far-right extremist
she says the left is making jews choose
our progressive values or ourselves
she says almost as upsetting as having a
member of congress repeatedly saying
things that evoke the most horrific
episodes in jewish history was the
response to omar's words on the
progressive left
instead of expressing support for
american jews horrified that a sitting
congresswoman
a person with access to state power who
has a vote on whether the most
on whether the most powerful military in
the world goes to war they started a
hashtag on twitter
i stand with ilhan she says that
every human being should oppose
anti-muslim attacks on her which of
course is true
but her supporters went further they
based their defenses around a bizarre
self-contradictory combination
of denying that her words evoked
anti-semitic stereotypes while
implicitly admitting that her words did
invoke those stereotypes with elaborate
deflections
and what about isms and then she quotes
alexandra ocasio-cortez
and of course bayanger sargon is correct
but she is as progressive as you get on
the left and even she is saying the
democratic party has botched this now
here's the thing
i was very worried in 2015 2016 about
the mainstreaming of the alt-right the
alt-right
has not been mainstreamed they they've
been forcibly ousted
from the republican party they are not
tolerated
yeah i was really worried about in 2016
and i was right to be really worried
about in 2016 and i was the number one
target of alt-right hate in 2016.
in america so i know of what i speak
and i spoke out and the left said yeah
we have to speak out against this stuff
now the mainstream left is saying stop
speaking out about this stuff
because it might hurt ilhan omar or it
might hurt the democratic party or it
might hurt the anti-israel cause
so i ask you again american jews i'm not
even asking you on the basis
of of shared ethnicity because i don't
care about shared ethnicity
if you care about your cultural
jewishness
if you care about jews being targeted
simply for being jews
if you care about slurs against jews
becoming widespread and that conflated
with anti-israel sentiment
how can you vote in favor of this party
or support this party how
you're gonna need to explain it to me
again i'm not even saying go vote for
donald
trump i understand your problems
i'm not going to say you have to vote
for republicans i am going to say that
if you continue to vote for this party i
don't know what is going through your
head or
at the very least i have to question
whether you have very much
cultural even cultural connection with
with the with
judaism or with being a jew
because let's face it jews are now under
attack by the mainstream of the
democratic party who are willfully
ignoring anti-semitism
in order to prop up their intersectional
coalition this is not a matter of
principle for democrats this is
political convenience
well political convenience allows some
bad actors through the door and
democrats have been championing them
ilhanomar is on the cover of rolling
stone
this week with the head of the house of
representatives
unbelievable okay speaking of disgusting
left behavior there was an amazing thing
that happened yesterday
martha mcsally who's the senator from
arizona and a former air force pilot
she was in a hearing about sexual
assault in the military and she let slip
that while she was in the military
she was sexually assaulted by a superior
my drive to fight against
sexual assault and the ranks is not from
the outside looking in
and it is deeply personal like you i
am also a military sexual assault
survivor
but unlike so many brave survivors i
didn't report
being sexually assaulted like so many
women and men
i didn't trust the system at the time
the perpetrators abused their position
of power
in profound ways and in one case
i was preyed upon and then raped by a
superior officer
i was horrified at how my attempt to
share generally my experiences were
handled
like many victims i felt the system was
raping me all over again
okay so that is you know a brave thing
to come out with it is
um because obviously she's speaking out
against the system in which she
participated i mean she wasn't not not
participating in the rape but she's
speaking out against the military
in which she was a member and for her
trouble she was ripped by jill
phillipovic she's a feminist
a supposed feminist because real
feminism is attacking women who are
victims of rape apparently
joe philippovich tweeted this is
complicated by the fact that mcsally is
a member of the exact movement
that is hostile to sincere and holistic
efforts to combat violence against women
and that folds misogyny into much of its
politics but feminists do want all women
to benefit from our gains in other words
martha mcsally the fact that she came
out and explained that she was raped
you know that's complicated because
she's right-wing because she's
conservative
that really complicates things again if
you are militarizing rape
in order to attack conservatives if you
are
if you are ignoring anti-semitism in
order to shore up your base
let me suggest that your party has a
serious moral problem i don't want to
hear anymore i i don't want to hear any
more about how the left is great at
policing itself the left is garbage at
policing itself
garbage i've said for a long time at
least when the right sees people
as a general matter we try to police
ourselves right roy moore is not sitting
in the senate because the right at least
tries to police itself
steve king isn't sitting on committees
because the right tries to police itself
name the last democrat who was so
extreme that they were actually ousted
by their own party name them
okay the last time i remember is when
cynthia mckinney was basically exercised
by her own party
or excised by her own party and that was
back in like 2003
it's been nearly 20 years since the
democrats policed a damn thing
it's absolutely unbelievable but i guess
it's not that unbelievable when
political convenience
overtakes principle which it clearly has
for the democratic party joe lieberman
he uh he came out and said former
democratic vice presidential candidate
he said that democrats will be held
accountable if they don't act
on representative omar's comments
i i think this is far too hopeful
congresswoman
omar's statements clearly do not
represent the thinking
of most anybody else in office in the
democratic party
but if if they start to mumble
in response to her specific and clear
anti-semitic statement then then the
party itself is going to be
held more broadly accountable for having
similar feelings which i know they don't
so
uh again i say uh this this is a moment
of testing moral testing
well they tested and they came up short
end of story
the democrats were tested they came up
short but
really should we be surprised they've
been tolerating this sort of
garbage in their ranks for for years for
a very very long time
for a very long time and that's not
that's not
any shock that now all that's happened
here is just clarification all that's
happened is that the veil is now off
that's all that's happened it's not that
jeremy corbinization of the party took
place over the last 24 hours is that
this party was moving toward jeremy
corbyn for years on end and finally the
last vestige
of pretend opposition to anti-semitism
is stripped away so long as ignoring
anti-semitism is politically
convenient for the democratic party how
horrifying
and how sad for the country really you
should have two parties that oppose
anti-semitism
and now the democratic party is openly
embracing it openly embracing it and
pretending it doesn't exist
amazing alrighty well time for some
things that i like and then
some things that i hate so things that i
like today
shout out to senate majority leader
mitch mcconnell who had the best line of
the day yesterday he was asked
specifically
why he is bringing up for a vote the
green new deal
but not house resolution one which is
the democratic plan
to basically remake voting across the
country and would make voter fraud
significantly more easy
mcconnell has asked why you bring up one
bill but not the other you're opposed to
hr1 you also post the green new deal
why is the green new deal getting a vote
in the senate when hr one is not
because i get to decide what we vote on
a cocaine mitch dropping the hammer
right there and breaking a smile as he
does it a rare smile
from coke and mitch that of course is
exactly true the media wished that they
got to dictate what
cocaine mitch votes on but that is not a
thing that is happening okay other
things that i like
is the thing i like and hate i will say
the documentary on hbo leaving neverland
about michael jackson we talked about
michael jackson at length yesterday it's
it's
difficult it's certainly difficult to
watch it's pretty stomach churning
it is well made and it is worth it is
worth
the viewing because again we can all
learn moral lessons from looking evil in
the face
yes i'm talking to you democrats so here
is a little bit of the preview for
leaving neverland
everybody wanted to meet michael or be
with michael
and then he likes you
i was seven years old michael asked do
you
and the family want to come to neverland
we drive in and forget about all your
problems
you were in neverland it was a fantasy
the days were filled with magical
childhood adventure experiences
playing tag watching movies eating junk
food
anything you could ever want as a child
it's like
hanging out with a friend that's more
your age
just kid things they were just doing kid
things
he just came across as a loving caring
kind
song i mean just super disturbing stuff
super disturbing stuff but it is it is
worth the watch okay time for some
things that
i hate
so tom perez the head of the dnc he has
now put out a statement saying that he
will not allow a fox news primary debate
he says i believe that a key pathway to
victory
is to continue to expand our electorate
and reach all voters that is why i have
made a priority to talk to a broad array
of potential media partners including
fox news
recent reporting in the new yorker on
the inappropriate relationship between
president trump
his administration and fox news has led
me to conclude that the network is not
in a position to host a fair and neutral
debate for our candidates now listen
if he wants to say fox news leans right
editorially that of course is true but
if you're saying that chris wallace and
brett bear
can't con martha mccallum can't conduct
a normal debate that of course
is absurd on its face it is also rather
absurd for
for tom perez to say he wants an
objective basis for debate that's not
true he wants a
he wants a network that is going to kiss
his candidates rear end
and we're better to find that in places
like cnn
and as you'll recall donna brazile who
ended up becoming the head of the dnc
near the tail end of 2016.
she admitted that she used her former
position as a cnn commentator to relay
questions ahead of debate
to hillary clinton during the democratic
primary
she said in october a subsequent release
of emails revealed that among the many
things i did in my role
as a democratic operative and dnc vice
chair prior to assuming the dnc
chair position was to share potential
town hall topics
with the clinton campaign she said my
job was to make our candidates look good
and i worked closely with both campaigns
to make that happen
uh-huh so but but don't worry cnn will
get a debate
also i'm sure that abc news will get a
debate you recall that
back in 2012 george stephanopoulos an
actual former staffer for bill
and hillary clinton in 2012 you'll
remember that he
randomly in the middle of a primary
debate asked
asked mitt romney about birth control
why because it then set up the entire
line of attack on romney that there was
a war on women it had nothing to do with
anything no one was talking about birth
control didn't stop george
stephanopoulos from going there
governor romney do you believe that
states have the right to ban
contraception
or is that trumped by a constitutional
right to privacy
uh george this is an unusual uh topic
that you're raising the states have a
right to ban contraception i can't
imagine a state
banning contraception i can't imagine
the circumstances where a state would
want to do so and if i were
uh a governor of a state or a legislator
of a state
i would totally and completely oppose
any effort to ban contraception we
should allow the people
to express their own views through
amendment and added to the constitution
but this idea that just should that be
done in this case pardon me should that
be done in this video
this is george stephanopoulos objective
news anchor i'm sure george
stephanopoulos will get to moderate
debate this year
george stephanopoulos was an actual
clinton staffer who wrote in his memoirs
about legitimately about hillary clinton
that upon
her husband's victory they looked at
each other with tears in their eyes and
she said i love you george and he said i
love you too hillary
that guy can moderate a debate but not
bret bear or chris wallace
good for president trump president trump
then blasted the dnc said fine you don't
want to do this
i won't let any of the fake news
networks do a debate with me he says i
think i'll do the same thing with the
fake
news networks and the radical left
democrats in the general election
debates
this seems to me an appropriate response
frankly okay other things
that i hate so just terrible news alex
trebek revealed yesterday that he has
stage four pancreatic cancer which is
which is pretty terrible obviously
bad diagnosis here's what he had to say
about it this week i was diagnosed with
stage four pancreatic cancer
now normally the prognosis for this is
not very encouraging
but i'm going to fight this and i'm
going to keep working
and with the love and support of my
family and friends
and with the help of your prayers also
i plan to beat the low survival rate
statistics for this disease
truth told i have to because under the
terms of my contract
i have to host jeopardy for three more
years
so help me keep the faith and we'll win
well we'll get it done obviously we're
all praying for alex trebek
he is great at his job you'll recall
that just just last year just a great
clip of alex trebek
uh football 400. i can tell you guys a
big football fan
tom landry perfected the shotgun
formation with this team
dallas cowboys uh do you think we should
go to commercials
these penalties are simultaneous
violations by the offense and defense
that cancel each other out
and they are called offsetting penalties
let's look at the
thousand dollar clue just for the fun of
it
if you guys ring in and get this one
i will die
alex rebecca great at his job obviously
we're all praying for him well
we'll see you here a little bit later
this afternoon i'm sure i'll have a lot
more to say at that point nancy pelosi
in the last few minutes has come out and
said ilhan omar just doesn't know what
she's saying that's all
just doesn't know what she's saying i'm
not kidding you like literally in the
last five minutes
nancy pelosi came out and suggested that
she is not anti-semitic she just doesn't
understand the full weight of her words
oh so that's what we're gonna go with
here
all right sure we'll be back later this
is why you should subscribe so you can
get two more hours of the ben shapiro
show
or alternatively we will be back here
tomorrow and we'll recap it all for you
then i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
senja villarreal executive producer
jeremy boring
senior producer jonathan haye our
supervising producer is mathis glover
and our technical producer is austin
stevens edited by adam syavets audio is
mixed by mike caromina hair and makeup
is by jessua olvera production assistant
nick sheehan the ben shapiro show is a
daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2019